hey welcome to my crib this mansion
belongs to me I paid for it
come on this of course is the living
room it's one of my favorite rooms in
this house that's mine
fully paid off it is fully paid off so
for me different shapes are very
important
you got round square and triangles my
favorite shape of all time obviously is
circle this phone I told you circle with
my favorite shape $14,000 of course this
is state of the art record player it has
a remote control says face command on it
because it sort of commands the space
doesn't it $17,000 fully paid off this
is my favorite section of the living
room I call this the sink
I call it to think and as you could see
you know I love circles and so there's
guys here what kind of cube would have
more circles on it than a die there
isn't anyway let's see what we're all I
bet it's a six [ __ ] we'll do it again
six six so that means I'm gonna have a
lucky day here these are among my most
prized possessions these are based on
friends of mine they were married and
then they had a really brutal divorce so
I had to have them separated as you can
see she's carrying various fruits grapes
apple that's a pineapple over there
$13,000 this one was only $7,000
all fully paid off let's go to read the
part of the house this is of course my
most prized possession it's a from
Postman Always Rings Twice which is a
great movie it's about a postman this
whole thing is over $100,000 it's fully
paid off not a big deal to me I always
eat breakfast here of course it's not
breakfast time but they've already eaten
but I'll eat here in the place that I
own that is mine and I just kind of like
look out and I go I must have done
something right in the previous life you
know all right let's go outside this is
my backyard this big rock I had put in
because I was like you know if it's a
backyard and it doesn't have a big rock
what's the [ __ ] point it's actually a
fossil and inside of the bones of a
t-rex 82 grand hey Doc this pool is
actually one of the biggest privately
owned pools in Los Angeles George
Clooney has one but it's it's his is
slightly bigger but mine is deeper so
[ __ ] you George
and this actually ha ha ha
[ __ ] look at this place this is the Tiki
lounge I mean look it's got everything
you want it's got circles as as I had
said before I love circles this is from
Easter Island and this is the changing
station these are actual cheetahs that I
killed and they all belong to one family
baby dad mom and the order that I killed
them in was baby first then mom and dad
was upset not for long because that
killed him and this is where I changed
so please come back but right now you
got to go home all right
[ __ ] of God
[Music]